c'est une pièce inaccessible au public
l'atelier de restauration
ici les médecins de l'art interviennent
sur des oeuvres altérée par le temps ou
des sinistres ce jour-là marie et sophie
sont au chevet de sculptures abîmé lors
des inondations du printemps 2016
la quasi-totalité des collections
stockés dans une réserve provisoire à
deux pas du musée ont été immergées
durant 72 heures ça a été tellement
violent tout a été tellement cogner les
oeuvres se sont cognés les unes sur les
autres
donc les zones de fragilité chaque
oeuvre à sa zone de fragilité
ce bas relief de 1839 d'antoine et ex
venait d'être restaurée au moment du
sinistre
il a passé cette longue journée dans
l'humidité emballé dans un film
polyester
j'ai toujours la vision de l'oeuvre
quand je les sorties jaune avec des
feuilletage avait vraiment l'impression
qu'on allait se retrouver avec un
millefeuille absolument irrécupérable
après un travail de collage et de
consolidation marie applique du pastel
avec minutie
elle masque les remontées de tanins afin
de retrouver l'aspect plomb du plâtre
c'est restauratrice indépendante ne sont
pas artistes elles respectent des règles
d'éthique
il ya toujours une part d'études de
l'oeuvre pour comprendre comment
l'oeuvre a été fabriqué on en parle on
n'attaque jamais une restauration sans
passer par la phase est une chose qui se
faisait avant mais maintenant c'est
inconcevable sur cette oeuvre de
triqueti l'ange de douleurs porte bien
son nom il a souffert à en perdre sa
main j'ai effectué des comblements avec
un enduit
vinyliques qui est
adapté au plâtre et chaque intervention
même nécessaire doit être réversible
pendant des années des choses ont été
faites un peu par des gens qui n'étaient
pas forcément en forme et enfin qui
était pas formés qui était pas forcément
habile et des choses qu'on remet en
cause après donc dans dans quelques
années on peut tout à fait remettre en
cause cette intervention là donc c'est
important qu'on puisse l'éliminer s'il
ya besoin
une fois la restauration terminé il y a
tout un travail de documentation un
carnet de santé qui va suivre l'oeuvre
toute sa vie ça peut aussi être utilisée
par les futurs restaurateurs si un jour
il arrive quelque chose et que les gens
sont amenés à travailler ils sauront où
on est intervenu avec quel produit
comment et ça c'est vraiment essentiel
demain nous suivrons la conservatrice du
musée
elle attend avec impatience les
premières oeuvres restos